is amazon actually reconsidering keeping
the expanse or do they have another plan
for the franchise
welcome to soundtrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
right so in previous videos i've talked
about how amazon initially were
considering making the book 789 of the
expanse into a trilogy of movies they
had gone as far as doing some sort of
loose storyboard now i am using the term
storyboard quite loosely but it was a
visual presentation of book 789 so that
they could be pitched to executives to
try to decide whether they wanted to do
this or whether it was something they
could even manage
now i have also reported that amazon
have already gone off that idea they
don't think a trilogy of movies would
work they think it'd be far too
expensive and they wouldn't be able to
do it justice anyway
but they might have another plan why do
i think amazon might actually have
either another plan or might be
reconsidering their position well i've
also done another video talking about
how hbo and potentially netflix have
already made contact with alcon they've
already said to alcon that if amazon
decide not to pick up their right to
make the 789 and that the rights for
distribution return back to alcon as is
part of their contract with amazon then
hbo max would be very interested in
producing a tv series for their network
but then on james s a cory's twitter
feed there was an interesting message he
put out does anybody know anything about
this
and then shared the comments that you
can see here i just had a very
interesting survey sent to me by amazon
and they're asking me whether i would
like to see more of the expanse i hope i
haven't messed things up by saying oh f
yes
now the stream then goes on to have a
few other people claiming to have also
had this survey from amazon now i looked
into this and i can't confirm whether
this survey did go out or not but what i
have been told by people that work close
to mgm and amazon that is something
amazon do they do send out very limited
surveys to regular customers and there
are some people that actually pay to do
these surveys could a survey have gone
out from amazon asking for more
information from customers about whether
they want to see more expansion or not
a couple of things i want to mention
here
amazon don't care as much about viewing
figures and other streaming platforms
are exactly the same they don't care as
much about viewing figures as say a
normal network they care about
subscribers and whether viewers generate
subscribers for them so a product like
the expanse is quite good for a stream
of service like hbo max for example
because it has a hardcore following
there are people in their hundreds of
thousands potentially that will follow
the expanse to hbo max from amazon so
that's why hbo max are very interested
but amazon have said that the expansive
over haven't they well not really what
they actually said was the expanse in
its current form is done
now those are very interesting words and
why i was actually very interested by
this idea of a trilogy of movies because
that would be continuing the expanse in
a different form wouldn't it so maybe
that's what they meant
well there is another rumor
now this is a rumor that i immediately
dismissed when i first heard it but it's
a rumor that suggests amazon might
actually be in the early very early
stages of trying to produce two spin-off
series
now i couldn't get my head around this
why would amazon produce a spin-off
series of a tv show that by all accounts
has been cancelled that's perhaps not
actually done that well hasn't had the
viewing figures they hoped for is this
something that's going to be the idea to
bridge the gap between books six and
seven could amazon be thinking about
producing two new tv series that
entering around that universe in and
around what's going on in book six
it could add on a great deal to the
universe and to the franchise
and then at some point in the future
maybe return to book 7
but have a couple of new projects that
bridge the gap
now this does actually make sense in a
couple of ways because showrunner aaron
shankar has talked about that the show
isn't really cancelled it's just on
hiatus now again that's quite a
confident thing for the showrunner to
say by all accounts amazon have said
we're not doing any more expanse so why
would shankar be so confident well it
would make sense obviously if this rumor
about two new spin-off series was true a
few of the actors have also made a
couple of cryptic statements where's
chatham has talked about the fans being
very happy about what's going to be
happening in the future and that he
would be very well happy to come back to
the expanse
some of the actors have already moved on
to different projects but nowadays
particularly streaming networks a couple
of actors being in a couple of different
projects at the same time is quite
common so there's no reason why those
actors couldn't return very easily to
the expanse so perhaps this is the plan
amazon have no intention of losing the
expanse
they have gone on a break warner
brothers are sniffing around but at the
end of the day amazon hold all the cards
they hold the distribution rights and
they have very thorough contracts with
alcon but we have to ask the question
could the expanse become a really large
franchise there is no point amazon doing
this unless they think they can produce
something that's really exciting that is
going to get people hooked
at the end of the day the expanse is one
of those tv shows is going to become a
bit of a cult classic for me it's a bit
like babylon 5. i genuinely think it's
even though hasn't maybe had the massive
viewing figures they hoped for people
will still be watching and talking about
it in 20 years i can tell you i'm on a
couple of facebook channels that are
devoted to the expanse and the fans are
seriously devoted they love everything
about the show because for one it's a
gritty realistic sci-fi show it is
actually set up in a way that it could
actually be reality in a hundred years
or so
that's one of the reasons why people
love this show so much and i don't blame
them i'm a big fan myself but what do
you guys think do you think this idea
that the amazon are actually preparing a
couple of spin-off shows is feasible do
you think it has enough popularity to
make that a realistic opportunity for
the future
these shows are incredibly expensive to
make and amazon would really have to be
committed if they're going to
sign up to do something that's going to
cost them eight nine ten million dollars
an episode potentially
but amazon at the same time are just
spending 750 million quid on the lord of
the rings and they are in a constant
battle with hbo netflix and disney plus
for content
and if warner brothers is genuinely
sniffing around this project and hoping
to snatch it from amazon would that be
enough to make amazon think that yes
this is a project they want to continue
with because if they don't continue with
it the rights will revert back to alcon
and alcon will be able to sell it to the
highest bidder
so get in the comments tell me exactly
what you think and if they were to do a
spin-off series who do you think would
appear in it
what sort of project would you like to
see i would really love to know what the
series hardcore expanse fans would love
to see if they did do a spin-off show
that was sort of linked in around the
time frame of the end of book six
so get in the comments tell me exactly
what you think guys and exactly do you
want to see this now so if you want to
support the channel and become a side
tracker you can hit the join button
please go ahead and do that now also if
you are new to the channel please like
subscribe hit that bell notification do
all those lovely buttony things
and as always guys please stay safe i'll
see you next time
you